music and that mirror on the robot and
his creator have left the laboratory
again there on the stage of berlin's
camisha oppa to test me runs perceptions
[ __ ] was the hospital fit immunes in
tiny what challenges muon is easy for us
like recognizing faces this table is
almost skin colored so that confuses him
it seems silly but he's really just
analyzing a camera image or directional
hearing we almost instantly know where a
sound is coming from but this space is
so much echo that a machine like muon
has difficulty or what immunised is hot
off guard robot maker montreat here it
has been working on me on for six years
now he's preparing the robot stage
career together with performance artists
from the gob squad and singers from the
Commission OPA we kind of made a short
list because there's a there's a few
projects here in Berlin that are looking
at artificial intelligence and actually
our first port of call was was was
Manfred Manfred is a very articulate
he's very artistic as well and he was
completely open to the idea and really
embraced it and immediately had ideas of
how this would also be very useful for
his research so it was kind of love at
first sight gob squad artist Sean Patton
has been fascinated by autonomous
intelligent robots since he was a child
of course the machines and star wars are
different from neuron but ultimately
he's expected to make decisions for
himself on stage and the robot is even
meant to show feelings even if he
doesn't know the word
we're interested in creating a real
situation where there's a real task to
be filled and this is very much like the
atmosphere of a scientific experiment
they want to set the robot off doing
something real and see how it succeeds
and see how it fails and that's very
much our approach to performance it's
live it can fail it can go wrong we
learn from it and make it different or
better the next time for both the
artists and the scientists the long-term
project has already brought all sorts of
benefits believe me about informing my
visitors and rehearsals we've had
situations we've never had in the lab
singing large spaces I've noted here the
problem of near and far if something
happens very near the robot while 20
people are moving and making noises up
stage and it often looks back there for
several minutes although the actual
action is down stage so directing
attention is something we can study much
better by experiencing natural
situations and correcting it now it's
back to the lab to reprocess everything
that happened today right down to the
last detail